who are you
as i'd said is a movie that i think
first ended up on a list of
of wouldn't be great if uh list
uh wouldn't it be great if we could do
this as a movie
probably 20 years ago because it's a
great story
of a uh of a young man that that
realizes his father
is um is essentially one of the world's
greatest
um super villains one of the world's
greatest criminals
and and how do you process that and how
do you deal with that as a as a child
and how do you how do you evolve beyond
that and the heroism needed
to uh to break free of that and grow
beyond that and even in our film
to to realize that uh that there are
many sides
to all stories into in the the world's
perception
of of his father and his perception of
his father um
is more complex than perhaps he
initially he initially thought
that was a great driving story for us
that we wanted to
to explore someday looking for a
filmmaker to to do it
was obviously as it always is important
and destin creighton coming in
and again dedicating his talents he's an
amazing filmmaker who does amazing
movies that have been um uh on the
smaller budgeted size compared to a big
marvel movie
but coming in and giving his personal a
vision
to this story of this father and son and
really this family
was very special and then how we could
find somebody to play shanghi
was his biggest question when he signed
up as uh as director our producer
jonathan schwartz
and uh casting director sarah finn
looked at
hundreds of people and simu came up
relatively late in the process when you
just start to get to that point of
maybe it's not going to happen because
what you want is everybody in your inner
circle
the producers the filmmakers to see
somebody and go
look at each other and go we found this
person this is the this is the one we
hadn't we hadn't
had that on shangxi uh at this point
and simu came in and sarah finn had seen
him before and brought him in again
and he did great he did a great uh
reading with destin he then did a great
chemistry read with uh with aquafina
who's gracious enough to do that
and i will say he you know a little bit
was who is this fellow let's look him up
that's what you do nowadays
you look up who is this guy and he did
have a
uh a um uh
infectious uh uh personality on
online in uh in in the way he interacted
with the world
and with fandom of of his show that he
was doing in canada at the time and with
a sports team that he was a fan of that
was doing well when i happened to when i
happened to
to search him so he's kind of the the
real deal
and uh and bringing a new marvel hero
into the fold is never easy and always
there's a lot of
a lot of pressure on us and i'm sure on
the actors but simu has uh has pulled it
off in ways that again
i'm very excited for audiences to uh to
finally uh see
in september
throughout my life the ten
rings gave our family power
well that's what's fun about the mcu at
this stage is we can do something like
chongxie introducing a brand new hero
into the mcu and into the into the world
at large
but that subtitle and the legend of the
ten rings actually connects it back to
the very beginning
of the mcu the ten rings being the
organization
that uh kidnapped tony stark at the very
beginning of iron man one
and that organization was inspired by a
character called the mandarin in the
comics
and going back to iron man one we've
been talking about when do we when do we
bring this character to the to the
screen
and only wanted to do it we felt we
could do it supreme
uh justice and really and really
showcase uh the complexity of this
character
which frankly we couldn't do in an iron
man movie
because in iron man movie is about iron
man in iron man movies about tony stark
so shane black in his film and his uh
script that he co-wrote came up with
this fun
twist that we love to this day and uh
turned out to be trevor slattery
just because that version wasn't real
didn't mean there's not
a leader of the ten rings organization
and that is who we meet for the first
time
in uh in chongqi and and again
talking about actors making making these
characters come to life
tony liang playing shanxi's father and
the leader of the ten rings
is another pinch yourself dream come
true moment because he's one of the best
actors of our time
and very excited to to have him
introduced to i hope a whole new fan
base
uh who might not be aware of his
spectacular uh work that he's done
you got this
thank you we just recently released the
uh the final trailer for shangshi the
end of which
had a character that looked very some
fans said this
looks like a character they hadn't seen
in many years name the abomination
fighting a character that looks like
wong and i can say
um that the reason it looks like that is
because that is abomination fighting
wong yes
um and again a fun thing to have a
character that
that that we haven't had on screen in in
over a decade um uh show up uh
again in the mcu and to see fans on that
little tag of the
of the trailer um recognize that and
embrace that
uh is great fun throughout the years
we have never interfered
until
chloe had expressed interest in in
marvel many years ago
even when when brad winterbaum our
producer on uh
black widow was looking for a filmmaker
her her name came up she'd done a great
film called the rider
and and um uh
she ended up not not coming in on that
film i don't believe and and
we're very lucky to get uh kate
shortland to direct uh that movie at uh
at scarlet's
suggestion uh but when when we were
working on eternals and our producer
nate moore
was was coming up with this uh pitch to
really embrace
one of jack kirby's greatest creations
for marvel um
amongst all of his great creations but
the eternals this
this race of immortal beings who've been
on earth for
for millennia is one of his best and
he he asked chloe to come and meet and
they really just
clicked on this notion of a history of
humanity and what it means to be human
and the viewpoint of that through these
characters the eternals
and she came in with a pitch that
that got into visuals which was which
was beautiful but more importantly into
these characters these are 10
new characters into the into the world
which is a very difficult thing to do
and she embraced that challenge and had
a unique viewpoint for for every single
one of them
and i'm happy to say that from that
initial pitch and meeting
to the near final version of the film
where we are now
um she has both won a handful of academy
awards in between
and delivered on her promise of uh of
what the eternals could be
and i look forward to to people seeing
that one as well
i love you my sons
remember this place
oh it was always our hope
at marvel studios to to be able to pull
off even a little bit
uh in a cinematic form uh
what publishing had been able to do in
the comics for
for uh for 70 plus years um
and that is and that is everything from
from the genius of stan lee and jack
kirby and steve ditko and
and all of the uh uh spectacular artists
and writers
is that they can tell honestly stories
as big as the big bang
and the foundation of the universe
itself and the foundation of reality
and tell something as small and moving
as
you know peter parker's origin story or
any of that moment in the loki series
when tom hiddleston is watching himself
in clips from endgame
it is so heartbreaking it is so moving
well that show also has
uh uh space lizards and deals with
and deals with a time itself it is
both that makes marvel marvel it is
being able to do the world outside your
window on a very personal emotional
level
and come at it from a viewpoint that
hopefully makes us
makes you think about your place in the
grander scheme of reality in the
universe
and speaking of eternals i think of
i've seen seen pictures of jack kirby
and his
at his little drawing desk in his house
and thinking the imagination of that man
pouring out onto that page
um and now and now uh the incredible
artists
led by chloe of doing it in in cinematic
form
is amazing it's bringing the human
imagination to life
on a personal level and a cosmic level
that makes
marvel i think what it is
there was a time when it looked like
marvel studios would not be involved in
in spider-man movies going forward for
sony um
it was only a few months but it was it
was uh
an emotional few months for i think all
of us on all sides
in a very public few months for whatever
reason um
uh but yes i had thought if it were
going i i
i always want to look at the bright side
and the bright side was we got to make
two great
uh spider-man movies um with amy pascal
and john watts and tom rothman and
tom holland uh and i was very proud of
that and very happy with that of course
wanted it to continue
um but but always want to be happy with
with what we have instead of upset what
we don't
luckily um uh
tom rothman and bob iger and alan horn
and
alan bergman and tom holland himself um
all realized would it just be more fun
if we just kept doing it
let's not let let's not get business or
politics in the way
because the deal always started with amy
pascal and i
having nothing to do with numbers or
contracts or
um politics it had to do with story
and a love of of spider-man and peter
parker and the marvel universe
and it effectively has continued like
that uh
and that's and that's where we find
ourselves now michael morby
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing what's up doc
i don't want to obviously talk about
rumors or speculation on what could
happen what couldn't happen
as it relates to any characters that
marvel studios hasn't hasn't brought to
the screen yet
but i will say what i've always said
which is having been in marvel for 20
years
i wouldn't dismiss anything i wouldn't
rule anything out when and how and where
remains to be seen it could it could be
you know any rumor that you read online
could happen uh anytime between tomorrow
and
never get down here and fight
[Music]
america you can't affect the real world
in here who's laughing now
you know i spoke earlier about
everything we do in marvel studios is
from the point of view of
of the audience and how do we make the
audience feel one way or how do we evoke
an emotion as an audience
i really feel like i learned that from
watching sam
on the spider-man movies where i was
just very lucky to be there
working for the former head of of marvel
studios avi rod
and just watching watching avi watching
uh laura ziskin the producer of that
watching amy pascal who ran the studio
at the time
and particularly sam raimi put that
those movies together
so now being in a position that that sam
is back in the marvel universe and and
working for us on dr strange
which aside from spider-man both steve
ditko co-creations
um what was his favorite characters is
is really quite
quite remarkable and full circle for me
personally from
my my journey at marvel and but really
it's just exciting
to get to watch sam work again and to
see sam raimi
put his sam raimi stamp on dr strange
on the multiverse on marvel and for
people who know what that stamp is
um they can be very excited and for
people who don't yet know what that
stamp is i can't wait for them to see
this movie
be blown away by it and go what else has
he done and delve
into sam raimi's uh a filmography
which is uh which is uh won the best of
all time hey yo
is this yours
[Music]
who are you yes i mean the death of chad
had hit all of us
um extremely hard and at the same time
as it hit the world because we didn't
we didn't know either um uh
and there were all sorts of of questions
and and our first thought
for many weeks afterwards had nothing to
do with the movie
it had to do with with him and his and
his family and his wife and his legacy
um and and really we were looking uh
to ryan coogler for guidance as as one
frankly always should about almost
everything in life i'd recommend
following ryan coogler for guidance um
and
and having the discussions which is
essentially came down
to continuing um the legacy of wakanda
and continuing um with with that
storyline in a very
um meaningful respectful and yet still
hopeful
and fun and exciting way um which is
which was which was difficult
um uh after after after
uh losing chad and i will say that
that ryan and our producer nate moore
and the entire cast and our co-writer
joe robert cole
um have done some remarkable things in
the story in the draft and and
the the team is assembling once again
and and cameras role
uh in the not too distant future on that
and it will be extremely emotional
across the board
but i think they have something um
very special in mind
[Music]
when you love something you fight for it
[Music]
we're the ones who changed everything
you know the definition of phases often
evolve
with the phase and and often i leave up
to writers and journalists
to decide that's for the that's for the
film historians to
tell us what the phases were about
truthfully
it is phase four was always about
continuing
in new ways and new beginnings um
uh even even uh you know with
with uh films that uh that seemingly are
concluding
story lines there are there are new
beginnings within them
and that's what was most exciting to us
about the opportunity to to make shows
for disney plus
about all of us at marvel studios
choosing to continue
um past endgame and pass far from home
once and leaving the infinity saga
behind to a new
a new beginning and uh that that i think
is what
is what people will be looking at uh at
phase four uh
hope i hope is having accomplished uh
but we're in the middle of it now
so remains to be seen we don't take our
foot off the gas we don't take anything
for granted
and we all work extremely hard to uh to
deliver